[Music]
welcome to the only PHP talk of next
it's really great to have all you guys
here I am one of the few PHP fanboys at
Google so I want you to all know that
this is a safe place
this is sanctuary no one's gonna make
fun of us here no one's gonna make fun
of the fact that our language acronym
stands for personal homepage so today I
also have Mark who is representing
instapage and instapage is a SAN
francisco-based startup that does
landing pages there if not the biggest
one of the biggest landing page products
out there and he's going to give us some
practical solutions for how they've used
PHP with Google cloud after I'm done
with some of the more high-level
technical stuff perfect so a little bit
about me my name is Brent Shaffer I do a
lot of open source stuff here at Google
so if you've used a PHP client library
to access api's at Google you've
probably used something I've worked on
also if you've ever had the extremest
fortune of implementing an oauth2 server
in PHP you've probably used my library
also so to illustrate and applications
like life cycle across Google cloud
platform I've built a small app that
will take a face image a base image and
then swap them so nothing too
groundbreaking here but all this stuff
is available on github in case you want
to run it the architecture is a
wordpress front-end just for kicks and
the backend is a Python script that I
found on github and that's been
containerized into like a worker type
back-end and so this is just this to
represent like a pretty standard you
know really basic microservices style
setup the clicker keep forgetting okay
so the first thing we're going to do
with this application is we're going to
run it on compute engine
and some of the advantages of compute
engine is we have this awesome cloud
launcher product that basically has a
bunch of stuff that most ppl pers want
to run already set up so that you just
you just click a button you can
configure a couple things like HTTP
HTTPS firewalls
you can add PHP myadmin that kind of
thing and we have those for WordPress
lamp stack we have it for XenServer also
so if you're into that kind of thing you
can run send server and we handle all
like the complicated licensing and stuff
and you just pay for it straight through
your billing account and stuff so you
know this is super low barrier entry
stuff I don't know if I can no I can't I
was actually gonna show you guys my blog
plug my blog burner tainment calm
because I ended up using this it took
like 20 minutes I launched a wordpress
instance using cloud launcher and then
it was ready to go so yeah it's pretty
great one other thing I wanted to
mention is they have auto scaling
instance groups so even though it's like
super simple stuff you can also you can
actually do pretty complicated scaling
rules with it and then you know make a
pretty resilient application so this is
what you get this is what my blog is
it's just WordPress running on my sequel
in a VM so does it does anyone see any
problems with this if you wanted to run
this like that scale or something like
does this seem like it's a sweet
solution we can all go home once we run
this you know so obviously like running
my sequel on the same instance it's not
very scalable right if you spin up a
bunch of these instances they're all not
going to be talking to the same database
and it's it's not great so what I've
done for this example and this again
took very little time is I deployed my
worker container onto this compute
engine instance and then set up
WordPress to use cloud sequel instead of
like the my sequel database that's right
there on the server so has anybody used
cloud sequel is everyone familiar with
this we just announced today that we
support Postgres something called sequel
which is pretty cool but
essentially just managed my sequel and
that way you don't have to worry about
setting up master-slave replication or
you know getting a requisitioning a big
beefy server we take care of that stuff
all right so I'm going to demo this real
quick and feel free to follow along on
your cell phones if you want to try the
the mobile UI is actually really bad
actually the UI in general is really bad
I don't think the the next branding team
is going to be super stoked if they see
this but so it's very simple let's say
you give it a very happy picture of me
and then I have a load of images does
anybody have anyone in particular they
would like to see my face swapped with
lots of this one right these are all
like public domain images of course
that's why I picked them this is now
calling the the Pythons back-end on
localhost and there you go look at that
that looks fantastic
all right sweet and go back to the
slides
so I'm actually running this
architecture which is just slightly
different what I've done is I've put
WordPress into a container that's
running on the compute engine instance
alongside the worker docker container
and that way they can still communicate
through localhost and what's really
great about this is this is actually
really really scalable this is a great
design so I can set up auto scaling
instance groups through compute engine
to scale this based on requests per
second things like that and what else
CPU CV usage and or you can actually use
custom metrics and stuff but this will
now scale to high heavens and if you
really want the scale you could use
spanner instead of cloud sequel there
and then you're like globally scalable
and crazy but you know the container
part is a significant step right it
can't just breeze over that so how many
people here are familiar
with containers or have built them okay
I can actually can't see anything with
these glasses on but I think I think I
saw a lot of hands that's great news
so containers are one of our favorite
things here at Google we absolutely love
containers if you want to know what to
get a Googler for Christmas get them
like a gift certificate to the Container
Store it's something he can go and pick
out his favorite container we love these
things we run these everywhere so to
talk more about containers I think a
good introduction is App Engine so once
again App Engine users as anyone here
use App Engine okay slightly less it's a
lot of people so we announced today the
GA of App Engine flex which is really
great App Engine flex is similar to
appengine standard but we run like
standard container format docker
containers so you can take pretty much
any container and stick in App Engine
you get all the advantages of App Engine
but you're running your own custom
container which is really sweet so what
we've done though the few PHP loving
Googlers at Google is we've spent a lot
of time building this base image for
your PHP applications and this thing is
available on github and it went into
beta this week or last week so it's you
know it's great and we would love your
feedback
obviously on it because PHP as all of
you guys know there's a broad user base
with tons of different types of PHP
users and we're trying to you know come
up with a runtime that that's really
good great for everybody so how does
this work so when you use App Engine it
just copies over your application code
building on top of the base PHP image
that that we've built and then it
deploys the resulting container right
and this container is built into Google
container registry G cRIO and if you're
not familiar with that that's it's
really basic it's just like docker hub
so it's like repository for images every
time you deploy a App Engine app it gets
put into this URL that represents your
project ID the version and service that
you just built so that's really cool
- because you can take that image and
you could deploy it to compute engine or
to Amazon or run it locally or to
container engine which is what we're
going to talk about later but so some of
the some of the advantages of using our
base image is we automatically install
of your dependencies if you're using
composer or you have a composer dot lock
which you all should be doing we support
all the non end-of-life versions of PHP
and will continue to as new versions
come available we have good logging and
error handling integration with Google
Cloud products we're using nginx which
is great Apache is also great and we
don't dislike Apache and in fact if
there was like a public outcry for
Apache support it would be pretty
trivial to add it the problem is it's
huge so it adds like a significant
amount of size to the resulting image
which slows down uploading and
deployment and stuff like that engine X
is also great so we've had a lotta luck
with that and that's what we use in the
container so PHP any configuration
pretty much everyone's gonna have some
customization required so you can enable
a set of shared extensions that we've
already compiled into the runtime or you
can add whatever custom configuration
that you need and you just drop that any
file in the root of your project and we
load it and same thing goes with the web
server configuration so with Engine X if
you drop in an engine X - app comp we
load that configuration and and run that
for the container so some security
advantages since secure is in the title
of this talk PHP and your extensions are
kept up to date so like I said all the
supported versions of those extensions
are sorry of PHP that we have when minor
releases come out we keep that regularly
up to date so when you build a player
container you get the latest version we
also have security patches so a little
bit on this because I think it's a
really cool thing that we've done is how
many of you guys have used parse
underscore STR
seeing that function nobody
wait this can't be this can't be real
this guy over here okay we got one this
is like a really common PHP function it
it takes a query string formatted string
and splits it apart into key value pairs
in an array right so if you haven't used
it all the libraries that you're using
have used it so this function is is is
great but if you don't supply a second
argument instead of loading those
variables into an array it loads them
into the the current scope that the
functions being called in has variables
so you can kind of see why that would be
a security issue right if you have you
know a dollar sign admin equals false
and then I type dollar side admin equals
true like in the query string then that
variables me overwritten so this is like
not good behavior this is this is PHP
from over ten years ago whenever people
were doing terrible things with
registered Global's and stuff like that
so we don't want yeah we don't want that
we don't want that at all this is what
we're trying to fight as PHP developers
all those haters like they keep saying
that our language isn't secure because
of stuff like this so what we've done
our runtime is we've patched this so you
can't you can't do this like you'll just
get an error that you need two arguments
which is which is really good we also
have for PHP five six only unfortunately
just for PHP five six because it's not
stable for 7.0 and above we have Soho's
and security extension and this is a
really really good security extension
currently what it does four five six
does it logs potentially unsafe
functions that you might call like exec
and pass through and things like that
and will show up in cloud logger so you
can kind of like audit your own
application code to see how safe it is
but it does additional things to I know
it it fixes some like it makes sure that
no your C extensions like your the C
calls are doing like improper things
with memory like buffer overflow and
stuff like that so it's yeah it's it's
it's good to have that in there we don't
use HT access which is generally
considered not good practice and we have
appropriate file permissions and user
permissions for the code that you deploy
so it's
executing his route and files aren't
right a bowl stuff like that okay talk a
lot so the two files that you need and
this actually still isn't like App
Engine this is just a container for your
application which is really nice the two
files that you need is PHP guy and I
this one and this is for whatever PHP
configurations you have for this app in
particular I'm using the GD extension to
do some image manipulation so I've added
that to my ini file I've increased the
maximum amount of uploads so that you
can upload a hundred faces if you want
and it might explode I don't know but
you can do it we have a few other
extensions that are installed for
WordPress BC math and off cache so we
also have the engine X configuration
file and this is all that's required for
WordPress and you actually don't need
this if you're using our default
configuration but I assume that most
people want to add this anyway but this
basically just points to the front
controller so all modern frameworks
these days use front controller so
that's essentially all this is used for
and then for WordPress you have a
special rewrite for WP admin so if
you're deploying to App Engine flex now
you need one additional file which is
app dot y amyl and if you use that
engine you've used app animal before
this is basically just a configuration
file that tells app dot or App Engine
how to deploy your application so in
this case we have runtime PHP to let it
know it needs to build from our PHP base
image and we have M flex to deploy to
App Engine flexible environment the
runtime configuration thing just says
our front controllers in the root of our
project so if you had Symphony it be
document root web if you had laravel it
be document root public and then the
rest of this isn't super important but
you can set environment variables in app
dot you mole and you if you're using
cloud sequel version to you you declare
your connection there it looks like this
this is basically the same as what we
have but now we have two separate
services
instead of two services contained in an
instance so some advantages of App
Engine we have versioning with
containers and URLs which is really nice
so every time you deploy you get a
time-stamped version for the image and
the and the URL as well representing
that version you deployed we have auto
scaling of course and and you have
default SSL and appspot.com which is
nice so let's go back to the demo now
here's Face Swap on App Engine ok is
there anyone is there anyone else you
guys want to see if not I'm gonna I'm
gonna choose okay I'm gonna go throng
over again this one's really good
because I apparently look exactly like
Ronald Reagan say slap against no effect
so if we look at App Engine and Pantheon
here sorry you see we have a default
service which is our WordPress container
and then a worker which is you know the
Python service so I don't know if how
interactive this crowd is but if you
guys all want to access this on your
phones and start actually face Wapping
with it from images from your phones we
can actually see these scale up and
that's pretty fun so I'm I would I would
love it if you guys did that I actually
haven't unjust before so I think it kind
of fun but you go to it was the the URL
was GAE dot faceswap
like to peace fac e-s wapt.com then that
will that will load this up you could
also go to cloud - next - PHP
appspot.com just redirects and in the
meantime I'm going to upload a couple
more
okay let's see if this works yeah that's
a terrible one I don't know it should
delete it depending on how many people
are doing this this might not work so is
anybody actually face whopping out there
I'm just curious raise your hand if you
are okay we got one two I got a handful
of people okay so this should definitely
work should definitely work I do this
again yeah when I tested this it it only
took like two different attempts
overloading the worker I sent in 20 and
within seconds it spun up five more so
I'm hoping the same thing happens now
come on yeah okay we got another one
sweet all right so that's I mean that's
that's a pigeon's it's basic all right
let's go back to the slides okay so
we're gonna talk about container engine
now so moving an application to
container engine now that you've done
all these other things is is hilariously
easy I mean there's not even really a
step you could you could literally take
the image that App Engine uses and
deploy at the container engine and
you're ready to go so you know it's it's
really simple one of the cool features
though that we have is let's say you do
have like a complicated app gamal or
something you can generate a docker file
that represents the container that App
Engine builds just with a single g-cloud
command that's g-cloud app gen config
dash dash custom and so that gets you a
docker file I haven't really explained
what doc file is yet so that is
essentially the standard docker
container format for building your
container and I'll show you an example
of that in the next slide so after
you've done that you run a docker
command to build the docker image and
then a g-cloud command to upload that
image to Google container registry which
again is like docker hub it's just a
repository for all of your container
images
so this is what you need for this happen
in particular you need a configuration
file for the two different services our
WordPress app and our worker app and
they need a configuration file that just
basically this is just establishes a
load balancer so you get an IP for your
service that's what a docker file looks
like this is the one I use in this app
it's incredibly basic all it does is say
we're using the PHP base image the
Google App Engine PHP base image so
there it is and then your applications
going to be installed in the app
directory that's what got generated
these service files so these are taken
by kubernetes and kubernetes is
container orchestration so in comparison
with what we did in container engine
where we had sorry what we did in
compute engine what we had was just two
containers running on the VM with
kubernetes you now have we're now gonna
have like a fleet of these containers
that we can scale up and scale down
individually we have a lot more control
and management with them and I'll
demonstrate that later but this is the
big value add of using container engine
so this configuration file is actually
really simple
it may look daunting but really all
we're doing is adding some arbitrary
labels here so we can have fine-grained
control over these containers and then
we have the the name of the let's see
yeah we just letting it know that we
need a load balancer for our WordPress
service so there's a wordpress
configuration you'll see we have a image
path using G cRIO so it always pulls the
latest image and we let it know we're
running in the container running on port
8080 and we again give it some labels so
it knows how to reference this container
later and we also have three of them
going on
this is our worker it looks pretty much
identical we have a different image path
different labels for it and we're gonna
use two of those so I already showed you
guys how to build this is the same thing
whenever you deploy these things you run
cube CTL apply and cube CTL actually is
already on your machine if you use
g-cloud and i assume everyone here uses
g-cloud so it's already there you could
just run this command and you're going
to deploy these pods to container engine
the architecture of this looks pretty
much identical to what we had before now
we just have container engine pods
instead of App Engine instances and the
difference here is pod is basically just
like this conceptual it's a it's one
level of abstraction above the compute
engine instances that you're running on
and this just allows you to have
multiple containers running in pods and
then you can take multiple pods and run
them across your instances your compute
engine instances so demo time once again
all right this time I'm gonna do my
other favorite which is Jack Nicholson
from the shiny so he looks really angry
but come on now he's happy
so uh actually I think that one that
one's probably scarier than this other
face so to highlight how powerful
kubernetes is I'm just gonna switch to
the terminal real quickly and edit the
one file that I showed you up there for
the worker and we can see we have two
replicas right down here everybody see
that so I'm gonna add a zero and then
just run that same command that I did
before cube CTL apply now if I do get
pods oops I do it quick they're already
up that wasn't that wasn't good because
you guys didn't actually see that thing
we're not before well not let me yeah
yeah okay good question so this is a
list of the pods and inside ready is the
containers so two of two containers are
ready so for our face [ __ ] worker pod we
have just one container running and
that's the Face Swap script for our
wordpress worker or our wordpress pods
we have two containers inside one is for
the actual Face Swap wordpress container
that we built and deployed that I talked
about and one is something that I didn't
talk about because I didn't want to
confuse anybody but it's not that
confusing so there's a sequel a cloud
sequel proxy running in another
container that's called sequel proxy I
can actually show you the let's see go
back here so if we look at this original
file that I had
after this container configuration I
have another container configuration
that basically spins up from another
container image a proxy server so the
wordpress instance is communicating with
a proxy server which communicates the
cloud sequel and that's how a cloud
sequel version 2 works I don't know if
anybody here that works at Google has a
good explanation for why that is I don't
actually know but if you use something
like spanner which is something we
announced recently and it's an awesome
database you don't you know you won't
need to use to do that you'll just
connect directly to it so yeah but this
all that's good because it kind of
illustrates it illustrates some of the
nuances of kubernetes that you don't
have to deal with if you use App Engine
to use App Engine you don't need to spin
up a cloud sequel proxy app index a
Bidoof environment Hales app for you
just connect to the database directly
and and it also illustrates how pods
contain multiple containers and then
they communicate the containers can
communicate on localhost within the
port's which is really nice okay so what
I was going to do I just want to do this
real quickly because I just love how
seamless this is so I just spun it back
down to two I mean it happens it happens
so fast
oops not that let's do 30 what the heck
I haven't done that yet I don't know if
that'll work
okay there we go so we already have most
of them running looks like yeah sweet so
for my final trick let's just blast this
thing with all of these images and see
what happens
come on come on
oh and okay they're coming in that's
good it's actually a little slower than
I expected it but great so I really like
the acquire currency guy up here I think
they all actually look better I really
like the Statue of David that one's nice
I like his his build it's a little
better than my own okay so let's go back
to the slides so we talked about Google
compute engine which is less managed but
it's the credible low barrier of entry
and it actually has the the the ability
to be very scalable and in just one
second mark is gonna come up and talk
about how they've built a global and
very scalable application using that
paradigm that I showed you with
containers running inside a compute
engine instance we've talked about
Google App Engine which is a lot more
managed it's highly scalable and we've
talked about Google container engine
which is a little bit maybe higher of a
barrier of entry but once you get used
to it you have an insane amount of
options you can deploy tons of services
manage them very easily so very neither
quite are there any questions sorry we
have Q&A at the end and we're going to
do all the questions then but is anybody
like confused before I headed over to to
mark what does this all make sense okay
sweet yeah well we'll be back for
questions in just a minute so without
further ado come on come on please
applaud mark he's great
[Applause]
hello everyone I'm quite confused why I
was invited because we use Amazon AWS
now just kidding
sure we have plenty of nice experience
we'd go cloud platform we moved to go
cloud platform in January 2016 and it
took over three months to learn and
evaluate various products go cloud
products against our application what I
did okay and before I start I will give
you a quick quick background about
instapage and me I am chief architect
instapage and I joined join instapage
six years ago and since she's very
beginning I seen grow from the start to
the end and instapage is the most
powerful landing page marketing solution
and it requires solid infrastructure our
application seems to be scalable but not
in the right way and speaking to my
colleagues I had a metaphor that we have
a fleet of buses 40 seats and one
wheelchair space each one and we thought
we have a capacity to scale but in spa
when we have a spike in need of
wheelchair spaces we are not efficient
because for example we have to send 10
buses for 10 people which require
wheelchair space and referring to our
application which situation was exactly
that we needed something more
because if all traffic came to our
monolithic up and there was some
bottlenecks entire application crashed
cost down time and after experiments
with kubernetes and and docker it was
clear that orchestration is the right
direction to our our system to scale we
decided to chop it and and split it into
small independent micro services but
gradually first we took out a latex
storage system which you can see on the
right and then we made a landing page
server system for our clients landing
pages and as you see on this diagram
after transition our court occasion was
smaller each the database was more
smaller - and it had to handle less
traffic and most of our traffic was
directed to lightwei lightweight
dedicated and out of scaled
micro-services
and serving landing pages we observed
that changes in load was very variable
and unpredictable and even we had a lot
of spike loads so we needed some kind of
soft sophisticated automated system that
could scale up and scale down so what we
designed was something like reverse
proxy we made it interrupt into docker -
to easy to start start them and the
event because the start time was very
crucial we even created in instance
template which pre-loaded docker image
to spawn them as fast as possible and
then everything we combined in back-end
services out of with auto scale turned
on and all traffic is going through the
HTTP lost browser which owes us to
direct traffic direct directed to zone
where visitor is from so visitors from
us who will see the content generated by
instances in u.s. from Europe in Europe
and from Asia to to Asia and that was
perfect solution for needs right and
each instance has been tested - and
proved that it can handle 200 requests
per second and with minimum 5 because we
have like find 5 zones 3 in u.s. one in
Europe and one in Asia we could gather
1,000 requests per second and if traffic
exists is more than 150 US per second
for while and any any instance the
system created new ones
to handle 202 traffic and if traffic was
going down system was taking down not
needed instances and real-life traffic
which looks like sometimes like that
some customers in FAMAS they do expect
high load but some do not and even if
with traffic like that and out of scale
system using auto scale back ends and
and andhaka we are able to handle this
kind of traffic without human input the
scale it could be a day it could be a
normal it's it looks like a day
sometimes quick question for you sure
what's the upper bounds on that graph
sir
well the upper bounds so it's just you
have a thousand requests for a second
and then it goes up to yes I do predict
that some people like sent creates a
campaign using AdWords and they tend to
stop it for some reason or they are
running out or for some reason the
traffic jobs and then come comes up if
if they campaign is resumed or something
like that
right and our system has to handle
500,000 registered users who made 1.5
million pages and traffic to these pages
generates 20 to 50 requests per second
just normally when you when you seen you
know the smallest the smallest usage and
but the high record we recorded was
12,000 requests per second and even over
that time system was fully functional
because it created 60 60 instances
Doctorow's obviously DDoS combined with
you
traffic but we had to we had to handle
it at least for for the beginning and we
have done like great work and we have
more efficiency and scalability and much
more stable platform platform and we are
ready to grow even more thank you so why
you're up here I have a quick question
so you said you have six micro services
plus WordPress front-end plus a PHP
back-end that is gradually being split
exactly the diagram I showed you on the
beginning is like nothing what you have
like in Rio yes we have we have like now
we have our code PHP application
WordPress and for self or macro services
because I count okay guys HPS and you
have all those those are all
containerized and they're running in on
a single compute engine instance exactly
exactly answer yes and thank you you
asked you you told that because we do
containerize everything because we want
to use kubernetes to manage our
deployments and just manage it so a
follow-up question then would be of
course what it seems like it's a good
fit for kubernetes deployment so I'm
curious why you guys made a decision to
use docker and compute engine as opposed
to going with container engine yes
that's what that's what's why we contend
Isaac everything gotcha
yeah so I I like I really like your
guys's story I think it's really cool
because it kind of shows where a lot of
PHP applications are right you start
with I I mean I I have personally been
involved with many PHP applications that
follow this trend of starting with a
massive monolithic application that was
built
a while ago and it's being split off
because it no longer scales well or just
because it's very hard to manage so you
guys are kind of in between where you
have moved away from the monolithic HP
app stage but you're still transitioning
to the fully orchestrated via kubernetes
/ container engine fleet of containers
so you know it's obviously a long
process to to move an application to
that you mentioned that you guys have
four or five other micro services that
you're in development to you scenario in
the development yeah and that you guys
are going to deploy pretty soon so at
that point you're looking at a very
strong use case with some like you brew
Nettie's because you're not going to
have those services needed and those
sources are not going to scale equally
right you're gonna want to scale some
more than others and everything else one
of the advantages of kubernetes I also
wanted to highlight and in using using a
container orchestration in general is
whenever you're pushing updates and
rolling updates for this stuff like I
did which was you know in a very very
small scale but when you're talking
about a very big scale like Mark's is is
doing you can use the the tags and the
labels you can do rolling updates grants
actually has support for just doing
rolling update so it'll take down half
your pods and deploy the new pods pretty
much transparently but another advantage
is if you have coupling between these
micro services where let's say you have
a an interface that's that's going to
break compatibility and so the way that
these two micro services talk to each
other it has to be up to it at the same
time kubernetes makes it very easy to do
that as well using those labels so as
long as you have the proper labels you
can rollover those services together so
I'm I'm personally not a DevOps guy
which is probably why I absolutely love
containerization in general and then
also even more so kubernetes and
container engine because it makes me the
DevOps guy like I'm not I don't do the
bash scripts and every other job I've
worked at
I turn over the application code to
these guys that are building rpms and
and and they live inside their terminal
and they're super fast typers and and
have all these hotkeys and that's not me
but the this kind of stuff makes that
very accessible and it makes you feel
like you are you know you do have good
oversight to your to your your DevOps so
actually because we have extra time I'd
like to turn it back over to my demo
real quick and show one other things so
you guys already saw the fleet of
containers that we deployed on the
command line so if you're using
container engine see we have this great
little dashboard that you can run oh I
messed up
this helps you visualize your cluster oh
thanks guys there she is
so the reason why this is indicating a
warning it's because I spun up too many
so I spent up 30 but I only have four
can compute engine instances that are
available so there's a handful of these
pods that couldn't be deployed because
they have a minimum amount of
requirements that can't be met so
whether it's CPU requirements or
something else yes so this is CPU
requirements so you know one of the one
of the primary tenets of kubernetes is
that it abstracts your container
orchestration from the hardware that it
runs on or the VMS that it runs on so
the scaling of the pods happens
automatically and it happens separately
from the VMS that you give kubernetes
because kubernetes is going to take care
of all that it's going to make sure that
it schedules the pods in the right
places in the best places so in this
case if I gave it you know a super beefy
VM and then I gave it a one CPU horrible
old VM it's going to use that if it can
for resources that it can to make the
best of it so that's pretty much it
there's QA it does get very complicated
I think one of the things I wanted to
show in this presentation is that it
doesn't have to be there's a lot of
really really good resources out there
on kubernetes and so I don't need to be
another one we have there's a Udacity
course online on kubernetes that's great
there's a lot of YouTube videos and
presentations that have happened at
other Google conferences that are great
but hopefully you guys get the feeling
that you can take an existing PHP
application or whichever one that you're
planning to build next and give this a
try give containers a chance because
they're great and creatives itself can
be a little bit intimidating
first because you do have these
configuration files and stuff which is
why App Engine it's great right you just
g-cloud app deploy your containers are
running in the cloud it's a good way to
dip your toe in and then when you're
ready for the next step you can go ahead
and pull those containers down and start
running a whole fleet of these things
and that's pretty fun
[Music]
you